in our series American wonders were
exploring places that make America
wonderful from majestic natural
landscapes to spectacular man-made
creations this morning we're in the
heart of the nation's capitol where the
Washington Monument is set to reopen to
the public tomorrow it was closed for
most of the last 10 years because of
damage and repairs now only on CBS this
morning our cameras were allowed up for
a special first look and Jan Crawford is
making history at the top of the
monument Jan good morning well good
morning I mean this is special like you
said no network is ever broadcast live
from the top of the Washington Monument
and what a view I mean look you can see
behind me the Lincoln Memorial and this
is a vantage point that most visitors to
the nation's capitol haven't had for
much of the past decade the Washington
Monument closed many wondering when they
would ever be able to get to the top of
this American wonder again it's a symbol
of America instantly recognizable 10,000
tons of pure marble anchored into
bedrock right below the swamp the
Washington Monument once the tallest
structure in the world with those
sweeping views of centers of power like
the Capitol and Pentagon it's brought us
a bird's-eye view of some of America's
biggest moments inaugurations Martin
Luther King Jr's march on Washington
it's an icon of this country I mean and
I it is it is and central to so many
people's visits to DC but the city
center piece set shuttered closed to
tourists for most of the past decade
2011 a rare East Coast earthquake
rattled the region raining rocks on
dozens of visitors who survived more
than two terrifying minutes at the
observation deck 500 feet up everyone
got out alive but the more than
century-old monument didn't escape
unscathed the earthquake damage was
extensive engineers repelled off the top
providing this heart-pounding look down
what they found
scared the park service enough to close
the attraction to tourists and trigger a
15 million dollar restoration project it
was a monumental task to fix the massive
marble obelisk with 36,000 separate
stones some cracked so badly the Sun
shone right in to begin engineers had to
build this exoskeleton of scaffolding
three years later the monument was back
open and we were there but it didn't
last in 2016 a cable snapped in the
monuments aging elevator and for three
more years no tourists could reach the
top now with some updates to the
elevator and this new security screening
facility at the base Washington's best
view is again ready for visitors and so
when those doors open on Thursday you
don't expect them to close again for a
few years I've seen they will stay open
and we look forward to probably five
hundred thousand people or so a year
but reopening the monument took one
thing the Park Service didn't have money
so billionaire philanthropist David
Rubenstein stepped in he poured more
than 10 million dollars into shoring up
the soaring stone structure and
Rubenstein invited us along the
ceremonial first ride up the refurbished
elevator for a view worth the wait
pay for the entire us death and
Rubinstein led us even higher another 19
feet up this ladder to the elevators
engine room for Rubenstein preserving
this monument was essential for all of
us your involvement in this project also
says something about
well I came from very modest
circumstances and I got very lucky in
this country so I really regard it as a
great gift by myself but it really is a
thank you to America restoring an
American wonder and confidence that
Washington can again reach its Heights